I already loved him you know as the
Punisher in season 2 of daredevil but in
a graveyard scene hmm
[ __ ] that are cute I liked it hello
reject nation its Greg Alba here its
Andrew here Andrew from the movie source
Channel it's here with me today guys
Andrew and I we're gonna do a
non-spoiler review of The Punisher we're
gonna do a separate video that will be a
spoiler review of the Punisher a series
the one on Netflix right now before we
go into that I have to give a shout out
to today's video sponsor a company I'm
very proud to be sponsored with right
now called Stardust Stardust as this app
that allows you to do 30-second
reactions for any film TV show or
trailer I used to always want to do
30-second movie reviews on YouTube now I
can just do it on the Stardust app I did
one for every single episode of The
Punisher so you've probably gotten my
overall opinion of it by now if you've
been following us on the apps but if you
haven't there's more stuff I'll be
covering over there if you want instant
feedback right away so download the app
and follow us at the real Rejects make
sure you get this guy on it too little
bum and depressed I thought we were
gonna be reviewing the 1989 Dolph
Lundgren Punisher like I already covered
it oh yeah an easter egg spoilers and
everything on our yeah really wanted to
be on that one yeah that one alright
we'll sell for this incredible odds are
non-spoiler review of The Punisher we
saw the first three episodes together it
took me a little while to readjust to
what this show was doing I always forget
that the Marvel Netflix shows move a
little slower than other shows I'm used
to or the movies in general this show
really has that vibe of kind of like a
No Country for Old Men or hell or
high-water sort of this modern-day
Western stone and style where it's very
character driven a lot of human drama
and then usually one brutal action scene
in the middle or towards the end of each
one of the episodes well how I really
felt overall about this show is that
it's a pretty damn good show
weirdly even though I love the show
and you love the show I can honestly see
why it actually has a rather low
percentage rating on something like
Rotten Tomatoes because if you really
pay attention when everyone's saying
about it you either hate the show or you
love it and that's a good thing because
the show commits strongly to what it's
about and what it's doing and how it
wants to tell its story you can't argue
with that wait you're gonna love it or
you're gonna hate it and we fall in the
spectrum of we love it and we'll go into
why I like that tone to that dark gritty
western style type of feel it had you
know especially from that a music by
Tyler Bates which I love that theme
music probably if not my favorite it's
right up there were dared oh yeah yeah
and it's open incredible yeah that's my
time I love that just got you getting
with the fields on that tone level with
the Western greenness but what I
appreciated about this show is there's a
lot of dark undertones about the Second
Amendment with gun control there's a lot
about political cover-up there's family
drama in there there's crazy violent
yeah very violent action sequences in
there too and I just feel like it all
meshes and blah and blends well and
there's also a lot of focus too on PTSD
and I could be totally wrong but the
last time I remember an MCU film or TV
show really focusing on PTSD was Iron
Man 3 with Tony Stark dealing with gamma
fication of what happened in Joss
Whedon's the Avengers it just did a good
mesh of blending all these different
layers of different things we had going
on in the show and when we weren't in
action moments or fast paced stuff like
on the slow burn stuff and the character
interactions and the family drama and
Frank you know filling that void of
having a family I just really
appreciated those moments in the
dialogue it was just there it was good
enough to when we did get two action
sequences I'm just so much more invested
in these characters so III just really
appreciated a lot more of the slowdown
moments well the action scenes have this
emotional intensity to them if there's
one thing if you don't care for the
human drama the one thing you can
definitely give this show is it has the
best gun action sequences out of any TV
show you will have ever seen it's the
first time I've seen a show room like
these gun action sequences are on par
with a lot of movies they're better than
Soho's think it John wick like yeah I
was watching like for a TV show this is
impressive because it's like military
tactical type of espionage gun action
that you're using so you will sort of
think of John wick as America
I was at the gym yesterday I was
thinking who would win in a fight the
Punisher Shaun one fact fanfiction
mashup right there yeah we've already
seen Batman versus the punishment in the
accountant so I mean yeah that match to
now but if you're really in this because
you just want to watch Punisher punish
the whole time you might not be so drawn
to it because they are reintroducing him
it's even a reintroduction from what we
got of him from daredevil season 2 I
thought it was just gonna be a
straightforward continuation of season 2
of where we last left off with him but
they kind of wrap that story up pretty
early on the Khan doesn't in the way
John wick too does it yeah John way too
opens up with like oh this stuff with
the Russians isn't over yet oh it's over
now like in the first scene yeah and
that's kind of what they do here without
really spoiling it and it starts a whole
new story one thing I appreciate about
all these Marvel shows they all have
sort of this sub-genre to them daredevil
is the one that's a real vigilante story
Jessica Jones is the private I knew our
story Luke Cage is that like black
exploitation type of story I don't
really know what I are faced with this
one the backdrop to it is a story of
veteran soldiers dealing with PTSD and
how they handle trauma and recovery
because this story is a real personal
character study of Frank Castle and
first off if you don't like the human
drama I don't give a [ __ ]
Jon Bernthal blows it out of the waters
is credible he is so good in this
freakin role you know what Frank castles
performance reminds me of I feel like he
has the emotional acting chops of Robert
De Niro and the grunt action heroism of
Sylvester Stallone the best of both of
those guys what's neat about it is this
story starts off a Frank Castle and he's
a loner and he's completed his mission
from everything he set out on on season
2 but you can tell he's still very much
haunted even though he's got in his
revenge
hasn't healed he hasn't truly grown he
still hasn't come to terms with his loss
at first this the show starts off on
this path of are we just repeating
territory kind of like how spider-man 3
does someone else killed Uncle Ben this
one I thought it was kind of doing that
but it becomes also the CIA thriller at
the same time there's multiple
storylines going on in this show you got
Frank Castle story through really trying
to find out what's really went on behind
his family's killing and you know get
his revenge there and then you have the
story of Mike Rowe his partner there's
yeah David Lee some adjectives you were
used to that I would say the guy in the
chairs the guy in the chair and
obviously his whole life has been
stripped away because of what he found
out you know it was going on in Frank's
missions on Kandahar yeah it was called
obviously now his life has been totally
stripped away and then you got a Madani
yeah you got agent Madani whose story
honestly I thought was super freakin
boring I didn't think he got interesting
until maybe like the fifth or sixth
episode out of a 13 season wait you know
we're not interested went to my god she
was boring I was gonna say kind of
spoilers when she was being banged by
yeah I mean yeah that was interesting
that was an interesting scene but other
than like a softcore porn I was like - I
thought there was too much focus and I
really thought they were trying to
emphasize like a lot of psychoanalysis
saying exposition to this character I
could care less about in the first like
six episodes of this this season and I
felt like they were trying to get me to
care about her when I just wasn't I felt
like we didn't need to spend as much
time with her in the first six episodes
okay yeah I was just gonna say I totally
get what you're saying I think what I
appreciated about what they were going
for with her character was showing her
that she is you know someone obviously
who has lost someone close to her kind
of like Frank and yeah she wants to seek
out justice too and she wants to find
the right path but she's doing it in
such a corrupt setting that it's making
it very difficult than like it just adds
more tension like this woman has to go
through so many obstacles you know so I
think I appreciated that more you know
for the character but I get why you felt
like bored towards the character maybe
you know she wasn't given the best
performance I like
more about the plot elements I didn't
care about the human characterization
drama elements over that they kept
throwing in my face so she's only one
part of this story that I didn't care
for him so halfway through the show and
then you also got this one character who
I wasn't sure the entire time but we'll
talk about in the spoilers captioning
Lewis who is this young soldier struggle
with terrible PTSD from coming back from
Afghanistan you really spend a lot of
time with this guy and the first half of
the show my words going with it I like
what they're doing and then this actor
is great but is this really gonna tie in
and it does one thing you got you got to
be patient with this show yes because
there's a lot of things that they keep
cutting back to you're kind of wondering
is this gonna tie in is this really
gonna matter in the long run and it all
eventually does you also got the story
of Curtis who is old friend of Frank he
knows Frank's alive he has these like
group therapy sessions he's PTSD or
therapy yes he took over for Captain
Falcon yeah especially they all saw the
character of Billy Russo who I forgot
who Billy Russo eventually becomes
Prince Caspian reference Caspian sue
becomes I forgot who he eventually
becomes and then I looked up the actor
on IMDB after I watch the third episode
at IMDB credits the name of who he
becomes and I was like he's not a
spoiler but it kind of ended they said
you've already watched all the episodes
gonna become the whole time in it so if
you if you got who Billy Russo is don't
look him up because it'll ruin pretty
much the last couple episodes of The
Punisher for you but he's great he's a
sexy yeah yeah he's not a bad-looking
dude I watched every episode of my
girlfriend and every time he came on why
don't you mind him yeah I got so
self-conscious last time I made love
with my woman I had to imagine I was him
interesting feeling yeah but anyway
perform better hey whatever it whatever
makes you do better buddy miss character
is really good and you don't get a
definitive villain up front you know you
have to wait a while to find out who's
the real villain of this show but
overall this show it's a slow burn show
it really takes its time sometimes a
borderline I fell like in the first five
episodes it kind of goes borderline
in dead territory you're really
stretching things out because you have
13 episodes even though I finished this
show going I loved it I still feel like
it could have been condensed to 10 or 11
episodes I do I don't feel like they
needed 13 episodes especially in the
first few episodes are like this could
have moved a little bit quicker and also
there's a story with my crows family I
really like this which is really good
because my crow he's hiding out and he
has to stay hidden from his family who
thinks he's dead and so Frank Castle
ends up watching after them so this
story is a long tale of grief what you
know PTSD from coming back from a war
can do to you and it's this weird story
of vengeance love recovery family it's a
cool introduction into a different type
of origin tale for the Punisher if you
think you got the origin tale of The
Punisher and daredevil season 2 it's not
this is a reinvention and this is a new
type of origin tale remember this one of
the early teaser trailers they show the
shot of Frank all you know bloodied up
and he's dirty and he's working hours
later Frank has to heal if there's any
Marvel a character has to heal what it's
this guy that's a Wolverine boy yeah
that guy can not get taken down he's
dirty and then he has the punisher shirt
on that scene comes in pretty late into
the season but when it comes in it
really dawned on me why they use that
moment as a teaser trailer because
you're like oh this is the punisher
being reborn right here you're
essentially watching the introduction of
how we got the nickname of the punisher
in season 2 and this right here is the
definitive vigilante we're gonna come to
know and probably follow for another
season this was a gripping show it takes
its time it's paced slow it all pays off
especially by the end of the ship and
the violence is brutal at times it's
haunting it's probably Marvel's darkest
show they've had because it's a human
show there's no super element Jesse
Owens is pretty dark too but this is
this is but there's always the thing of
the super ability elements I could kind
of take down some of the darkness a
little bit because it still feels very
fictional this feels very real other
than the fact that Frank survives the
impossible a lot yeah it still feels
very real really
my final thoughts - just adding to your
point I think what I really appreciate
about this show that I didn't feel so
much in defenders I really felt this the
stakes and especially during the end and
I mean whenever they're in moments of
panic or threat but I also felt the
threat level - like even though I know
the show's 13 episodes there were
moments where I really you know was
fearing for Frank's life or whoever he
was trying to protect on screens you
know I thought they did a good job of
like again just getting that fear level
up and really making you feel you know
the stakes of the calamity of the
situation are getting you you know
scared for the character so that that
when they do do the impossible
it's well-earned kind of like Bruce
Willis and and I heard there's a lot of
themes in this show grief choices
politics there's a whole lot going on
Yankel cover up and one thing I'll say -
is that you you've got to watch it all
the way through the end because there
are stuff that you might not find so
intriguing in the first half by the last
half of this the show all that stuff
that I initially did it wasn't too
invested in becomes very much of a
strong emotional investment by the end
of the Shep's alone so yeah there's this
show I'd give it like I do it like a
nine out of ten I give it rip probably
around an eight point eight or a nine
somewhere run there no no all right guys
well what did you think of the Punisher
did you love this show did you hate it
did you feel punished but you feel
punished right you can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell you download the Sardis app and
follow us at the real rejects post of
plenty on there and really do you love
being a part of that community and also
become a patron reject today most
importantly though clearly this guy
knows his information make sure to
subscribe to the movie source channel on
YouTube Andrew Gordon one of my great
friends Andrew if he does a lot of great
videos on there one of them that's
coming up right now is an Easter eggs
and references video all about the
Punisher so make sure to follow
subscribe to him right now so you can be
notified when that video is out to give
America